[Música]
momento de nuestra revista de prensa con
Marta Moya Marta Buen día para usted
palanca Buenos días Bueno es un gusto
Marta y vamos a abrir nuestra revista de
prensa con la noticia de Turquía que
sigue reaccionando el mundo y los medios
por supuesto a los resultados de las
elecciones ocupan el primer puesto los
titulares cuéntenos por favor de los
medios locales si Ángela vamos dos
portadas de la prensa turca vamos a
empezar con el miliyet que titula este
lunes erdogan otra vez el presidente
volvía a ganar los comicios
presidenciales con el 52% de los
sufragios y venció a su contendiente que
mal que le echaroglu por más de dos
millones de votos esta portada destaca
una frase de erdogan ayer en su discurso
de Victoria diciendo que no había ganado
él sino que habían ganado los 85
millones de turcos y que no estaban ni
enfadados ni guardaban rencor a la casi
otra mitad de Turquía que votó en su
contra también esta portada destaca las
palabras del líder opositor
quilicharoglu que animó a sus a
continuar con la lucha hemos destacado
también la portada de economy que
también Turco titula este lunes erdogan
vuelve a ser presidente a la espera de
que se confirme los resultados porque
los resultados que tenemos Ahora son los
de la agencia anadolu pues erdogan se ha
impuesto con el 52,14 de los votos claro
este resultado lo conocimos en la tarde
de ayer pero en las últimas horas llegan
cada vez más reacciones internacionales
Así que en esta escala de los medios
también se han hecho eco de la victoria
de erdogan Y si le parece vamos a
empezar con el yasira Pues sí Ángela al
jazzira dice que erdogan y su Victoria
Sella el lugar del presidente Turco en
la historia Ya llevaba 20 años y ayer
consolidó cinco años más ya supera
ampliamente a mustafa kemal a tatur
fundador de la República de Turquía que
estuvo en el poder 15 años hemos
destacado también el medio ruso comersan
que dice que a pesar de la oportunidad
teórica de la oposición erdogan volvió a
ganar las elecciones textualmente la
comunidad de expertos cree que un enorme
recurso mediático jugó a favor del
presidente así como problemas evidentes
de carisma en su opositor los resultados
garantizan que Turquía siga en la misma
línea política también con Rusia ambos
países tienen acuerdos energéticos en
los próximos años pero dice este medio
ruso que todavía pueden surgir muchos
inconvenientes en la vía ucraniana Y es
que occidente va a presionar para que
Turquía por ejemplo desbloquee la
entrada de Suecia en la otan y en ese
sentido Pues en el informativo decíamos
que ya el gremio y felicitó a erdogan
pero ahora estamos esperando la llamada
de Joe biden y ver que saldrá de esa
comunicación que será plenamente formal
en ese sentido le pido que vayamos al
Washington post sí Ángel Washington post
titula el camino político de erdogan de
alcalde al gobierno unipersonal de
Turquía
ya más de dos décadas en el poder han
reformado la política turca y su papel
en los asuntos mundiales esto dice el
Washington post erdogan ha tenido que
enfrentar también momentos difíciles
como el intento de golpe de estado en su
contra en el año 2016 pero esa figura
polarizadora que además ha presidido una
influencia vertiginosa no ha dado una
respuesta Clara tampoco a Los afectados
por el terremoto de febrero de este año
y aún así pues ha ganado las elecciones
eso dice el Washington post no nos puede
faltar tampoco de economista hoy que
cayó la lira turca Así es Ángela y di
economías dice que erdogan es reelegido
y Turquía pierde la mayor oportunidad
para reparar su democracia como en otras
ocasiones los rumores sobre la
desaparición política de erdogan fueron
muy exagerados eso dice the economist
que también sostiene que los medios de
comunicación han apoyado esa Victoria
electoral de erdogan que al final Muchos
medios privados se han convertido en un
brazo de gobierno de erdogan dándole una
antena ilimitada de minutos y sin
contrastar sus siempre controvertidas
afirmaciones finalmente tenemos lemont
Lemon Angela titula este lunes erdogan
el insumergible ni la crisis económica
ni su vaga respuesta a los terremotos
del 6 de febrero han hecho que el
mandatario Turco se hunda erdogan dice
lemón no deja indiferente a nadie sus
seguidores lo ven como un padre y sus
detractores lo critican por cultivar lo
que dicen es una estatua de Sultán Ahora
tiene el poder para rediseñar Turquía A
su antojo eso dice lemundo Así ha sido
vamos a destacar también un análisis del
británico de Guardian acerca de las
reacciones de occidente a esta
reelección Pues sí Ángela porque dice El
guardia antioxidante vive entre el miedo
y la esperanza tras la reelección de
reyeta hiperdogan hay que evitar y esto
dice el análisis del Guardián que
erdogan caiga en el regazo de Vladimir
Putin aunque muchos analistas
occidentales tienen algunas reservas de
que esto no vaya a ocurrir ya que el
propio erdogan ha dicho que mantiene
unas excelentes relaciones con el
presidente Ruso y se ha negado
sistemáticamente a imponer sanciones
contra Moscú después de la invasión a
Turquía dice este análisis también de de
Guardian que también es un poco una
bendición que arrogancia haya reelegido
Porque esa entrada hipotética a la Unión
Europea se va a quedar se va a quedar se
va a seguir quedando Perdón que no me
sea de expresión en la bandeja
dependientes y que además también
erdogan va a facilitar a frenar la
migración hacia Europa bueno de ahí nos
han visto avances en los últimos meses
Así que no hay razón para pensar que los
haya ahora pero Marta quiero cambiar de
tema y usted como buena española solo
puedo imaginar lo que ha sido ver las
elecciones regionales a la distancia y
todo lo que han desencadenado hubo estas
elecciones y fueron tan malas las
noticias para el partido de gobierno que
Pedro Sánchez ha decidido Llamar a
elecciones anticipadas y esto está
reflejado en las portadas de los
periódicos nacionales Pues sí Ángela
ayer una jornada intensa también en
España hemos destacado cuatro portadas
nacionales en España empezamos por el
diario El País que titula el partido
Popular arrasa en Madrid y multiplica su
poder territorial el partido popular el
partido hegemónico conservador en España
va a necesitar a la extrema derecha para
gobernar en la mayoría de autonomías
donde ayer ganó y que destaca el país
también que los conservadores en
términos absolutos ganan por más de tres
puntos al partido socialista el partido
gobernante en España hemos destacado
también la portada del abc una portada
muy conservadora y un medio muy alineado
al partido popular que titula este lunes
Sánchez arrastra al partido socialista a
la debacle el partido socialista perdió
en cinco comunidades y 11 de las 22
capitales donde gobernaba el mundo
también conservador titula el PP arroya
y el castigo a Sánchez borra al psoe del
mapa podemos que es el socio de gobierno
del partido socialista también
desaparece en muchas comunidades
autónomas y bildu que es la izquierda
independentista en el país Vasco
asociada mucho también a por la derecha
a ser a tener vínculos con la Banda
terrorista eta Ya extinta pues también
logró ayer un gran resultado Y por
último hemos destacado La Vanguardia que
titula el PP gana las elecciones en una
noche a ciega para el partido socialista
veremos Cómo se traduce esto en las
elecciones generales ya previstas para
el 23 de Julio sobre ello quisiera
rápidamente terminar con la editorial
del país y habla de este gran Triunfo de
la oposición Así es Ángela el país el
editorial titula rotunda Victoria del
partido popular España se tiñe de azul
que es el color asociado al partido
popular y que en muchos sitios el
partido popular hasta ahora líder de la
oposición tendrá que pactar con la
ultraderecha un partido que ha
cuestionado principales principios
democráticos por lo tanto el partido
popular también se enfrenta a este
dilema que marcar á la segunda parte del
ciclo electoral que concluirá como
decíamos el 23 de Julio bueno es la
alternancia política Así es Ángela Marta
Muchas gracias a usted y nos vemos
mañana gracias Ángela